Hey guys Grant Thompson (The King of Random) and welcome to my royal, round table
I was going to start off with a joke or some kind of a funny story, but in reality
I'm not really that funny of a guy so let's just skip that part [now]
I realize there are a lot of questions and comments about the way I do things that a lot of you have had for quite
A long time even though I do answer those questions in the comments sometimes most of you don't see them
So I'm going to do my best today to answer some of the most frequently asked questions
and if you have more then just post those comments in the description
And I'll do my best to answer those in the future now firstly
I have an announcement to make about CVX live I've been invited out to Orem,
Utah to appear for a [2-day] event and the reason that I said yes to go is because I want to meet you
So I just accepted this a couple of days ago, so it's kind of short notice
It's happening this month on March 25th and March 26. I'll be there on [Friday]
From 3 p.m. To 5 p.m.
For a public meet and greet so come up say hi ask questions, shake hands take pictures
Whatever you want the point is I want to meet you now on Saturday Night March 26
I'm going to be on the stage
Premiering a video that no one has ever seen before so if you want to see a video that hasn't been launched yet
And won't be launched you know for quite a while, then come out and see that
I'm really just going to meet you and to be available and to hang out
I don't have much [of] an agenda
So come pick my brain and let's get to know each other a little bit better. Alright, now
Let's move on to some of the frequently asked questions. These are comments that I see popping up a lot
I see a lot of positive comments, and I love that
But I'm specifically gonna address some of the concerns that you have here
And I don't feel like any question is too taboo. You really have legitimate concerns about the way
I'm doing things. I probably have a reason for the way
I do it but I'm happy to talk about it with you one of the questions
I get asked a lot is why did you change the quick clip music?
I'm sick of this new song I like the old music and I want it back now
That's a really good question and the main reason is because I no longer have a license to use that music the company that produced
That track took it off their website and no longer offer copyright licensing on it
So I don't have the ability to use that track any longer the other reason is because for over a year
People were actually asking me to change the quick clip music
So I finally tracked down a new track developed a whole new series
and then made
Change only to find out that the other half of people didn't want it to [change] and so we've got that battle of emotions
So I just chose [to] stick with the new quick clip [music] and not change it rather than having a knee-Jerk reaction
Of bouncing all over the place. [I] may change the quick clip [music] again, but for the near future
That's the template [that] I'm using and I'm going to keep it that way [all] right. Here's a comment
That says please do more videos. Why don't you make videos more often do more videos?
I would love to I really would
Now here's the thing [I] work 8 to 12 hours a day six days a week for the last five years
Making the videos that I do and putting them out every five days actually stretches me to the Max
And that's the fastest I can physically
possibly put them out
Producing and editing these videos is actually really really
Time [consuming] and difficult and if you'd ever like to know what goes into making a video king of random style
[I'd] be happy to share that with you. If it would give you some insight and help give some perspective
Why it's so difficult and takes so long to make these videos. I experiment. [I] prototype and some videos
Have you know eight to ten prototypes before I even film them writing the script takes forever?
and there's a lot that goes into these videos that I can't even begin to tell [you] about and I am
Physically and mentally and emotionally giving it everything that I've got if I can make videos
Faster I would but this is the best that I can do and honestly I'm getting tired
I need to take a little break so for the next month you may not see any uploads from me
That doesn't mean I'm [going] [to] stop
I've still got videos [queued] up
And I've got a lot of projects filmed and I'm going to get back to working on but I just need to take a little
Breather why do you upload the same videos over and over again [now]?
This is a question
I've seen popping up from a few different people who may just not understand the bigger picture
So let me explain videos like the mini Master sword a year ago
[I] cast a prototype sword out of aluminum with the promise that one day
I would do a tutorial of the finished product and now I've just
Released the tutorial on how to make the finish master sword now in other videos
I often feature or cameo other
projects that I [asked] you to look for in future videos and so of course [that] leaves the
Condition that I need to make that future video and when I make it and post it
It's not read up loading a same project
It's a completely new video that fulfills a promise that I made earlier, [so] another question says didn't you do this already?
Why do you make so many videos of the same thing are you trying to milk the view?
And the YouTube money [are] you out [of] ideas?
That's a really good question and let me explain
Why I do things the way that I do now when I design my projects. I like them to have multiple purposes
I don't like to do one thing that you
Never use. I like it to be purposeful, and I like it to have multi purposes
There's a big picture in my videos where a lot of the projects are interconnected
And you need one [to] do another for example in my rockets you need an iGniter
So I have an iGniter tutorial
but the igniters relate to the rockets which relate to the remote-control launcher which relate to the
Rocket launch Pad all these are separate elements separate videos, but they're all completely related to each other
So if you're going to make something like I don't know a silicone
Lego gummy mold I'd love to be able to use that [to] maybe build something like
Chocolate Lego Mario which you're probably gonna see coming up in another video, and if you don't have access to food grade silicone
Maybe you can use some [kind] of rubber. You can make yourself
So you see all these tutorials are completely different
but they are related to each other you can think of certain videos almost like a series for example making the styro-slicer'
There's a tutorial on how to use it [a] tutorial on how to make it. There's also
tutorials on projects you can do with it like the master store the styrofoam handgun and
Foam fighter jets to name a few so all those projects are interrelated and they do reference each other which I could see looks like
Uploading the same content being out of [ideas]
but that's just part of one mini series inside of this whole
Massive realm of videos and I do tend to run in random phases and once I leave one phase
I move into another phase another viewer asks. Where do you get your ideas?
[an] idea is really come from everywhere sometimes I see things online sometimes my kids are doing things that inspire [me] reading books
Experiences, I had growing up sometimes I see things on pinterest that spur ideas and sometimes other youtubers are doing things that give me ideas
That I want to take and modify now
I have never uploaded a video in my recollection where I've just taken an idea and copied it everything [that] I do I
Experiment with it. I modify it I recreate it
I turn into something different, and I give it a king of random aspect so I am constantly inventing creating
Experimenting and doing things new but they're all based on something that inspired me
So look in the description of my videos, and you'll always find
inspired by and
Usually a link to the thing that inspired me
And if you want you can compare the two and see what differences you may see
another viewer asked the question are you [going] to run out of ideas and
The answer to that is no
I'm going to run out of motivation to produce videos before I run out of ideas
Because as long as I keep living life and being inspired by things that I see and want to try I'm going to keep [making]
Projects, I've been doing it for four years straight
[I] guess five years now
And I'm going to keep going as long as I can keep [making] videos
Getting burned out on production is probably going to kill me before I run out of ideas themselves, but the answer is no
I won't run out of ideas. What did you study in school to learn all this I'm basically self-taught
I put myself through the school of Grant thompson using the internet personal experience. You know the experience of people around me and
Just thinking things [through] before trying them. I have been studying non-stop for last 15 [years] after [I] got out of school, but in school
Itself I didn't really study anything in [particular]
What do you do for a living is this your official job, or do you have a side job well?
I did have a full-time job
I actually just put in my resignation today
And I don't really want to disclose what that profession was but it was I?
Would say it's relatively prestigious in its industry, and it was very difficult to achieve
I've got Eleven years with the company that I was just working with and
[Thirteen] years in the industry total but officially as of today
I am focusing fully on YouTube which I was basically doing before but I
Make videos. That's what I do right now grant
Why don't you use the metric system?
And that's a very good question I get asked this all the time now. The metric system is awesome. We all agree
I grew up in Canada using the metric system
So I understand it but down here in the united states everything in the stores are sold in imperial measurements
[so] when I do my tutorials
It doesn't really make sense to do them in metric now if you're having a hard time doing the conversions
Just use the google tool because google will give you the answer and make all those conversions very easy for you
Your kids show any interest in your projects
[I] am starting to see a glimmer of hope in my kids here, but to this point. They really couldn't care less
They're all pretty young and they haven't really cared too much about what's been going around them but they are just starting to get old
enough to appreciate the projects and the videos and that's exciting because
Now I can start spending more time with them getting our hands dirty together [how] many videos?
Do you have saved up?
I have over 10
project videos and quick clips ready to go that gives me a little bit of breathing room so I can still release on schedule and
Make new content, but those burn up pretty quickly right now
[I've] reduced my schedule for posting every week, so every Tuesday
But I would like to get back on a once every 5 day schedule if possible
I'm just looking for ways [to] still have a little bit of free time because I'd really don't take [vacations]
[I] don't have fun, and I need to have a little more fun. I miss the mine vendors
Are you bringing them back so the mindbender trivias were just an excuse to give away some cool stuff?
I would like to bring those back, but I just focused on project videos for now and getting those guns with no distractions
[so] I will probably bring back mine vendors and giveaways whenever I can fit it in so look forward to that
Hopefully that answers most if not all of your questions for now
I am doing the best I can and I've always done the best I can to give 110 [percent]
Into all of my videos my goal is to reach the best quality content based on my own
experiences and to be really true and genuine with all the information [that] I give you so
I hope you feel that
I've had a lot [of] discouraging comments pop up lately that have really brought [me] down and hurt my feelings and
Frankly made me feel like I just want to quit making videos altogether, but I have pushed through that now
I'm kind of back on top of things
[I] got a lot of fresh new projects that I can't wait to share with you
And I want you to be a part of my future [videos] as well
I'm looking to engage with you back and forth a little more frequently and one of the best things you can do for me
Right [now] is to come out to CVx live and meet me in [person]. I need to know who you are
I need to know who my subscribers are to meet you face to face to shake your hand [and] to hear some of your experiences
watching my videos
That's the kind of feedback that I need so hopefully I can see you there CVX live March 25th March 26
Look at CVX live calm for the schedule of when I'll be there. I'll be there on Friday and Saturday
I'll put some links in the description
With a lot more information and remember the private [meet-and-greet] is going to be limited to about a hundred people
So if you want in on [that] make sure you get down and get your tickets quickly
[so] hopefully you got some kind of a value out of this video hopefully your question was answered and
Hopefully feel like we're able to connect a little more one-on-one [as] always
Thanks again for your support, and I'll see you in the next project video do them
you